Okay. If you were interested in respectful
political discussion on the internet, which
is a rare thing, consider the David Pakman
show subreddit@davidpakman.com slash R E D
D it, we've got moderators. The more than
16,000 of our viewers and listeners are regularly
participating there. And there were some interesting
posts this morning that I saw and wanted to
address.
One is, how many of y'all think Trump wins?
Reelection polls indicate top Dems beating
him, but those polls don't indicate turnout
ratios. I don't care if a bunch of Looney
boomers think Biden is more favorable. We
need younger people to turn out in droves.
Yeah. You know, yesterday up during the impeachment
livestream, I said, uh, I, there are a number
of scenarios in which Trump doesn't get reelected.
For example, Biden is the nominee and Biden
wins, or Bernie is the nominee and Bernie
wins. Or Warren is the like, I think conceivably
all of those folks could defeat Donald Trump
or Trump has convicted, uh, in the Senate,
although it's very unlikely, uh, on impeachment.
I still believe that from a statistical standpoint,
the one most likely scenario, the one most
likely scenario is Trump reelection. Now that
doesn't mean that that is a majority probability.
It might be.
It's a 40% chance Trump gets reelected and
it's a 5% chance he gets convicted in the
Senate and it's a 17% chance Biden's the nominee
and defeats him and a 17% so you see what
I'm saying? I'm not saying more than 50% but
I think it's still the most likely individual
outcome is Trump gets himself reelected. Now,
some people have been writing to me saying,
David, what's the advantage of saying that?
Like what do we gain by you saying you think
Trump's going to be reelected? You should
be doing this, you should be doing that if
you want shows that do that type of stuff
where they say, well, here's what I think,
but that would be perceived this way or that
way. So I'm gonna say this totally different
thing. This show has always just been, I tell
you what I think, and I don't calculate whether
I should tell you what I think on the basis
of how it might affect a, B, C, D. now, some
people might say, David, that's erratic.
You might be doing damage to the movement.
I reject the idea that merely saying, Hey
guys, this is an uphill battle. I still think
given how difficult it is to knock off an
incumbent president and how unlikely it is
Trump's convicted in the Senate, and how it
is still likely that with a small popular
vote loss, Donald Trump could still win the
electoral college. That's just my analysis
and I will always give you my analysis. Now,
we could disagree about what Democrats should
be doing on that basis, and maybe we do. But
that's the way I see it. It's an unfortunate
reality. Also from the David Pakman show,
sub Reddit, a poll that shows generationZ
is even more anti-Trump than millennials.
This was very interesting to see because you've
seen a really big effort from the wa, I guess
we would call the, uh, think tank, right?
Or the, uh, on-campus, right? Or something
like that to really start targeting younger
voters and they've been claiming victory.
They've been saying, you know, millennials
are very left, but the next generation coming
up, uh, is going to be much more conservative.
Now let me remind myself a gen Z years, the
a, that is people born between 96 and 2010.
Okay. Right? So even those 2010 will be now
be voting, um, in this upcoming election.
It turns out that they seem to be failing
despite all the money that groups are pouring
into attracting, uh, young people over to
their movement on campuses and in other ways,
gen Z, according to recent polling, is even
more anti-Trump than millennials. And we will
see how that is reflected in the 2020 election
results. But everybody's got to get registered
and everybody's got to go vote. And that's
where our focus should be.
Join the discussion on our subreddit@davidpakman.com
slash. R. E. D. D. I. T.